from the first moment that we learned of the
existence of a whistle blower around the Trump
Ukraine phone call corruption bribery fiasco.
I told you on day one Donald Trump or people
around him, we'll figure out who the whistleblower
is. And if they do, they will figure out a
way to leak the name of the whistleblower,
putting them in obvious and immediate danger.
And now we've learned that they've done it.
There's a guy who now works for horrible extremist,
extremely depraved Republican Congressman
Devin Nunez, who previously worked as an advisor
to Donald Trump, who leaked documents that
identify the whistleblower's name. The aid's
name is Derek Harvey. He gave notes to house
Republicans outing the whistleblower. The
goal of course being get the name in the record
of the proceedings and the house intelligence
committee because Adam shifts said that eventually
those records would be made public as part
of our report on the Trump impeachment inquiry.
We've also learned from the Washington post
that Republicans have been using the whistleblowers
alleged name multiple times during these private
depositions, meaning it is working and it
is working because they do not care that it
puts this whistleblower's life at risk. Mark
Zaid is the attorney for the whistle blower
and Mark Zaid says that his client's life
is at risk if his name gets out, that the
lives of the whistle blowers family are at
risk.
If their name gets out or if the name of the
whistleblower gets out saying, quote, exposing
the identity of the whistle blower and attacking
our client would do nothing to undercut the
validity of the complaints allegations. What
it would do, however, is put that individual
and their family at risk of harm. Perhaps
more important, it would deter future whistleblowers
from coming forward in subsequent administrations,
democratic or Republican? Well, yeah, that's
the point. Stop future whistleblowers put
this his life at risk in order to ruin their
life. And this has led to some far right and
news outlets like Oh, a N N one American used
network and the gateway pundit to start publishing
a name that they claim is the name of the
whistle blower. Notice that I'm not saying
what that name is. So understand the CIC nature
of this. The claims of the whistleblower have
already been corroborated even by people in
the Trump administration.
Wittingly or unwittingly, if you ask them,
they might not agree. They've corroborated
the claims, but they've corroborated the claims.
They put out this phone call transcript, which
is not a transcript, but it's the, you know,
they call it a summary. It's really just a
couple of excerpts of the transcript and it
is already damning to Trump with a Lipsey's
and, and uh, redactions. It's still extraordinarily
damning to Trump. Further incriminating Donald
Trump and this entire fiasco, Donald Trump
panics and starts tweeting all sorts of ridiculous
things. But then they still want to ruin the
whistleblowers life because this is just how
they operate. Tell me that what Derek Harvey
did feeding a name to Republicans in this
way is a prosecutable offense. I don't know
if it is. I've got a couple of emails out,
uh, to attorney friends. This is sort of out
of their area of expertise. They're looking
for an answer for me.
I don't know the answer. Is it a prosecutable
offense? What Derek Harvey has done, uh, if
you have a sense of that, let me know. Isn't
this closer to the treason that the right
claims the whistle blower has done than anything
the whistleblower has actually done? Aren't
we supposed to be protecting whistleblowers?
Isn't that one of those things that is supposed
to cross party lines? To the extent that we
still cross party lines in American politics
and we are supposed to protect whistleblowers,
I guess not the president isn't even doing
it. Is this obstruction? Is this witness intimidation
in a sense? Aren't we supposedly about the
rule of law under the Trump administration?
The answer is no. That stuff only matters
when it's convenient. When it's not, it all
goes out the window and further. I know I've
mentioned this before, but just to, to give
you the full scope of this, there is a double
standard in American politics when it comes
to whistle blowers and leakers and the left
is guilty of this as well.
Although right now we're talking about the
right, putting the whistleblowers life at
stake, life at risk, which is something different
altogether, but we see this in American politics
a lot. There's a whistleblower or a leak or
whatever and some information goes public.
If your side likes the content that has gone
public, you ignore how we got it and you focus
only on the content. If your side doesn't
like the content, you ignore the implications
of the content and focus only on the fact
that there is a whistleblower that it was
leaked that information in some cases was
stolen or whatever the case may be. This is
a status quo in American politics. That being
said, Republicans are going away further.
Republicans are actually working to put the
whistleblowers life at risk and the lives
of the whistle blowers family at risk. I'm
not going to participate in that. I'm not
naming the whistleblower. Eventually we may
know who the person is and it, uh, may, may
simply become part of the record. And at that
point, okay, we will revisit. But for now,
I'm not going to participate in this. Make
sure you're following the David Pakman show
on Instagram at David Pakman show. We've got
some great stuff going on there and make sure
you follow me on Instagram as well. Don't
forget about guys, uh,
David dot half-ton on Instagram. We'll be
back
right afterwards,